That was a tiring week last week, man,
with all the colonel dev.
I spent most of yesterday just doing a
whole bunch of a whole bunch of lifting,
kind of reposing a bit.
We're going to try to get some more
Devon today.
I think we're pretty close to done.
Well, not done fully, but like I think
we're very close to having an end to end
working useful prototype.
There's always one more thing, man.
There's always one more thing.
All right. So,
where last we left our hero?
I think we had the working forward
kernel, right?
This does not need to be this wide. Go
like this.
We're going to start on the RMS kernel
today.
I think if we can get this done and we
fix the multi-threading thing from Peru,
um I think we should be able to have
something reasonably performant as a
starting point.
They are, as far as I know, they're just
doing LLM stuff, man.
Okay.
So, yeah, this is where we left off. We
have a correct forward kernel, a
runnable backward kernel, but the
backward kernel is wrong.
And I had like um
I believe this was the math of it. Of
course, the obnoxious thing with this,
right, is um
yeah, the obnoxious thing is, of course,
I don't know if this is correct.
Multi-objective, you can already use
this for multi-objective RL
or goal conditioned RL is usually how
you formulate it.
Not hard either.
Okay, so this is the formulation that we
have.
Uh,
you're free for 15 minutes or now. Oh,
yeah. Let me look at drone stuff real
quick. Thank you. I told I told Sam and
Finn to bug me if I forgot to look at
the uh the drone PR. And here they are
dutifully bugging me for forgetting to
look at the drone PR.
did you want to chat about it or did you
just want me to look at it?
Oh, okay. Sure. That's what you meant.
That's no problem. Let me get off this
uni lab.
So,
we got
I mean, this is going to look like two
files deleted and then merged back. I
mostly want to see what the new code
looks like.
Okay. So, there is somehow you have it.
You got it to be a single end.
Oh, actually, I remember I had a tough
time doing this because I tried to make
it a single end originally and I
couldn't get it to work as like I
couldn't get it to work cleanly as 1 M.
Not great at multitask.
Get there from this code soon. I see.
But does it train like um can you train
it single task? like this doesn't break
racing or break um
you know the uh the swarm tasks if you
train individually, right?
I like how you have a ring buffer that's
literally a buffer for rings
at the same time. Cool.
Oh yeah. If anybody is looking for like
an example of how to write a good
environment, look at the code that these
two write. Like
the dronem stuff that they've done is
really solid.
See if I have any nets. I kind of need
to look at the Python file first to see
what you did.
Okay. Wait, how is this working then?
Because
I don't see anywhere that the train task
is getting specified. Right.
I see numb drones. I see max rings.
What do they do that is good? They write
code that doesn't make my eyes bleed,
man.
Like, look at this. We We'll go over it
in a second as soon as I can figure out
what they're doing with um
Okay, guys. Where can you tell me where
you are specifying the task that you're
training on? Because you say it's
perfect if you train separate, but like
where do you specify that?
It's just in C right now. Okay. So if
it's just in the C then you don't have a
way to specify
oh like hardcoded in the theh file. You
mean
you definitely want to be able to
configure that from thepy guys. So,
please do that. Even if it's just
passing like a task index, like a an int
index, like anything like that is fine
as long as there's something.
Let's go to let me see. So, it's drone
lib.
And then they just made a render. Cool.
That's fine.
So, let's let me make a sure. Oh, and
then they have tasks.
I kind of this is like a big enough PR
that I sort of just want to go look at
the
look from here
C.H.
And then you get one, two, three, four.
I think this is reasonable for an M this
size.
Yes, you can. What is create? You can
start with pure Python. You're going to
quickly figure out that it's actually
not that hard to just write C though.
You let them go out of bounds and then
you bounce them
Okay. So, these were like the targets I
had from the Yeah, I made a bunch of
these tasks. I remember. So, you pulled
these out. This is fine.
And then you did I want to see what the
new drone li looks like. So, this is now
a That's not bad.
Has the login here.
Yep.
Just one RK4 step
Okay, cool. So, this like this looks
similar to before, but then
run.h is now going to be
a very simple thing. Cool.
Okay, this is not bad. Then I was
originally wondering why you had broken
up like I was worried that the project
had gotten way too large, you know,
because you were breaking up uh the
project into a bunch of different files.
I think realistically there isn't a huge
need to have done that, but it's not
terrible either way because the thing is
like that drone lib really isn't a
general purpose library. It you really
wouldn't use that file directly in
anything that is not this end the way
it's written. So I don't typically see
the reason of breaking stuff up when
you're not going to include the code
somewhere else anyways. Um, but it
doesn't look like that that has become
an excuse to write twice as much code as
you need. So that's totally fine. Uh,
same thing with render. Render file
looked really short. Task file looked
really short. So that's like generally
all fine. I'm curious as to what you did
on
specification of tasks. I see this does
get a task.
It looks to me like you are still doing
um train on everything here.
Just looking tasks. Yeah. So, I
understand splitting out the tasks in
that sense. I don't know why you split
out drone lab, but I think it's fine
because like the only reason that I
really like split the main reason at the
very least that I um I tend not to split
up files is because people tend to use
it as an excuse to write way more code
than they need, right? If you're staring
at one block of 1500 lines of code in a
file and you know that you only need 700
lines of code, you know that you're
dumb. But if you have it split across
three files, it's way easier to like not
realize you have way more code than you
need. Um, but because you have more code
than you need, like you haven't run foul
a foul of that anyways. So, I don't
really care if you want to break stuff
up provided that the main thing of not
having too much code is satisfied. And
this looks like a reasonable amount of
code for this project. Uh, I don't know
what you've done with the task
specifications though because I remember
when I did this, I couldn't get the
drones uh to work cleanly on all the
tasks simultaneously,
which is why I had it split up
originally. And it looks like you have
this set up to train on all the tasks
simultaneously, which if you could get
this to work would be fine, but I think
given that it currently doesn't train
for that, you definitely need to have a
way uh from the Python like from the
config to specify the training task.
That would be the one piece of feedback
I have. And also, please stop hurting my
soul with um with two space tabs. Those
are the only two pieces of feedback I
have.
Like it is actually difficult to
visually track what layer of indentation
you're at when you have two space
indents like this.
Like which level does this line up with?
I don't know. I guess
is it?
No, it's this one. Like see it's like
Yeah,
that's all.
Cool.
Uh,
I suppose I can just merge this
so that you guys have something to work
off of.
I can do like a I will do a speculative
yolo merge
and I mean this is going to have to go
into 40 anyways, but I'll merge it into
where do you have it PR
Yeah, this is kind of my bad because I
have not set the uh the PR policies well
enough. It really should just be that
the PRs come into 40,
but I think
do I want to start now or not?
I think that it makes sense to just do
this
to just like merge this
I think that this is covered.
Let me just make sure that this is
Wait, how's it 16 files?
Drone race binding.
Let me just make sure this is not
touching anything that it shouldn't
touch.
an upgrade few weeks. Yeah. So, I'll
merge this so that you have something to
so people can like play with it more
easily and you can get cuz there are
some people in the Discord that'll be
happy to like look at this stuff
provided I merge it. So, I'll merge it
to make that easier for you.
I think what it's going to be is
starting in 40 the policy is going to be
um like bug fixes only to the current
version and then everything else gets PR
to the dev version.
Thank you folks.
Replace the drone with a puffer. We
already have enough environments that do
that.
Yeah, like this one. Oh, yeah. So, uh,
we have the final results in, guys, from
um the neural MMO experiment over the
weekend.
Here we are.
So, these are the final results.
Cheers, Finn.
This actually looks really freaking good
when you uh look at it this way, right?
I was showing it log scale before
like this.
Blue one is a single GPU.
So that's expected to be more sample
efficient, but that's slow as hell.
I don't know why that actually didn't
fully run either. But um that's slow as
hell either way. That's expected and
it's not very exciting. The exciting
result is uh is this one that the new
architecture is actually better.
All right, let's see if we can start on
our kernel.
over R.
Uh, does that make sense?
It does.
Yes, Sam PR for early stopping.
Oh, we just got lots of PRs today.
Welcome, K.
Yeah, I really should not have let you
do all this stuff to 3 0. This should
have all gone to 40, but it's that's on
me.
runs that are below early stop quantile
increases as cost increase.
And let me see how you've done this to
see if this is something I can merge
immediately or something I foresee being
a problem.
What are you doing? This is
currently reviewing Kyouung's PR for
early stopping on our hyperprem sweep
and then afterward fixing the RMS norm
uh gradient for our custom kernel.
We have this to this to fig uh figure
out and merge. And then we've got this
CUDA kernel to develop in the
background.
reinforcement learning. I've got lots of
content if you're interested on my uh my
X
and I stream all my dev.
I'm trying to figure out how you're
doing this, Kung. So,
after min cost, runs that are below
early stop quantile are stopped.
What does this mean?
Min cost is 600.
After 10 minutes
sweep needs data for early stopped runs.
Send data when steps greater than 100
mil.
Most of my work these days is
C, CUDA, unfortunately some C++ and
Python.
I'm most happy when I'm just writing C
though.
Wait. Logging threshold
is
minimum of 20%
of the total time steps.
I mean, this is literally going to be
one training step for something like
Pong.
No, all of our RL stuff is very very
performant.
So, Puffer is the fastest RL library by
about a factor of a thousand
and can literally train these models in
seconds on a laptop
faster than tiny. Tiny is a is not an RL
library. Tiny is like a general
framework. Nobody has RL code in Tinyrad
that is faster than Puffer.
Made a PR for adding setup instructions.
Oh man, we have lots of PR today. Yes, a
4090 would work fine as well. I that's
literally what I have on this PC that
I'm using here for streaming and for
running stuff locally.
Most of our GPUs we use for training are
4090s.
Hang on. Apparently, we're getting tons
of PRs today. So, let me see. Let me
finish this one
cuz I'm trying to figure out what you're
doing here and whether this is going to
work with a bunch of MS or not.
You have lots of time to learn some
stuff
since you're newer actually here.
Let me link you one useful thing.
I do try to help people out who are
earlier on and trying to learn stuff.
Um, this article here,
this has all of my best advice for like
general programming as well as ML and
especially how to view science and
research and such.
Um
it will probably a lot of the things
here will not make sense initially but
this is a very very good reference point
and this will save you a lot of time.
It's a pretty short article is too
pretty short article.
Do you have a full-time job? This is it,
man.
I finished my PhD just about two years
ago. And now I work full-time on high
performance RL. It's all open source,
but uh we also build like high
performance sims for uh for companies as
well. Do some contracted R&D and such.
I got distracted on this completely.
Where'd Kung go?
You are here. Okay. So, in that case,
I'm trying to figure out what you've
done here.
This is really really heristic. Hacky
Kyouong. Like I think you're going to
end up cutting off a ton of training
runs on a bunch of ends. Like
like right here. What happens if your
score is is like percentile, right?
You're going to cut off everything. like
you're going to prevent the thing from
actually optimizing fully.
Like you've got a ton of little
heristics in here. We do want early
stopping, but you've got to do it in a
way that's robust. I mean, unless you
tell me that you have sweeps on
everything and this actually somehow
works.
Sure, let's chat.
So, this will be a great feature if we
can do it. The reason I've never done
it, though, is it's kind of hard to like
come up with a good way to do it that
doesn't break other stuff.
Holy hell. Why do I have literally six
different DMs,
different people,
the last like hour,
whatever here? Puffer voice channel.
Hey.
>> Hey, K.
Hey, Joseph.
>> Let me turn your mic way up.
Say something.
>> Yep. Oh, can you hear me?
>> Yeah, you're good. Okay. So,
>> also share the screen because X is
laggy.
>> Because thing is laggy. Sure. Sure.
Uh
>> uh ton of heristics for sure. Yeah. And
I've been looking a lot of breakout
runs. Breakout is like the good quick
environment to test stuff on.
>> I've been trying to get it to be fast
and 40 mainly I've been doing lately.
>> I know.
Uh wait. Oh, have you shared the screen
or you're doing that?
>> Yeah.
Does it work?
>> Wait, why am I not seeing it?
>> They click and like click watch or
whatever.
>> Oh uh sharing their screen. Okay, got
it.
>> All right. Yeah. Furistic direct agree.
>> like this seems okay to like cuz this
will probably work for breakout, right?
>> But like this right here, this if you do
like driving, if you ran this on the
drive environment, this immediately
breaks, right?
>> So, so that that is the like third layer
the like hard thresholding, right?
>> Mhm.
>> So, uh in in the like high cost regime.
So,
Yeah, like I start that
is it so in drive van with the score is
the like percentile
>> right like 99%
99.9%ish
Uh
so
so the environments with score that has
like either very hard to maximum
will have no problem doing it and
probably benefit from it. But then yeah
like you mentioned drive
>> cuz percentile
>> for those yeah like I would
uh
>> well I mean we can think about this. So
what are the can you explain to me the
various heristics?
Um
can you explain to me like the various
huristics here?
Uh
wait so heristics in the
>> Yeah. So this one is 1.2
1.2 times cost
the maximum cost. Yes. So so far what
you have right now is the like a the
maximum of the like the par curve. So
like that's the almost like the highest
ceiling you have seen so far.
>> Uh it I the the cost to get the highest
ceiling you so far right and then like
you have spent 20% more than that then
like you should be able to at least give
me like 5% more on the score. So yes, it
will break on the the percentile score
but for the other like uh like normal
score based it will I I I think that
uh that will kill a lot like the long
runs that just go uh doesn't
that are not very informative. So, so
for like driving
for the driving or like the percentile
that like 99% 9% or 99.99
whatever those better I think those the
scores for those need to be switched
like the sigma or something so that like
there if you really care about the error
rate then yes it it should go into like
two sigma three sigma, four sigma, five
sigma or so forth.
>> And if the score, huh?
>> I mean, or we could have a metric that's
more robust so that it doesn't like
break on that.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I I mean that the the the
the sigma, right? Right. Right. Like if
you go over 99%.
>> Then and if you want to reduce the error
further like 90.99
like those won't cut it you will need to
say and time okay my error rate is two
sigma or three sigma or four sigma and
those will matter a lot and much more
informative. So that like in that case I
think score metric should change not the
not the like that
>> thenistic
>> I suppose
>> that
>> and then what's this one this is max of
cost in epsilon
>> uh
>> this is you put this in the in the PR to
some degree Okay.
>> Where where
this thing?
>> Uh
I'm looking at the figure. Are you
showing me the figure?
>> Yeah, I'm looking at the figure, but I
saw this like this log log a plus b or
whatever.
>> Uh log a plus b. Yeah. So, so the like
the coax is like we are playing in the
rogue space right. So the simple
quantile regression is fit while x is
like ro transformed.
>> So this means hang on so this is the
safe zone.
Okay so let let me just ask you a bunch
of stuff. So first of all the safe zone
here is half of the run or like what?
So for breakout uh that so like that the
like a mean load mean
like that is kind of the like
hyperparameter
that needs to be tuned for each
environment like I put it for 10 minutes
for for Euro MMO it might be like one
hour two hourish
>> and like the the goal there is to not
cut like aggressively
polarity.
>> Yeah. It's bad though that we have to
introduce hype like this is these are no
longer hyperparameters, right? These are
like hyperparameter. Hyperparameters.
>> Yes. Hyper hyperparameter. Yes.
>> I think if you start if you ever use the
word metahyperparameter, you're kind of
on you're not doing so well. Uh you
don't want to have meta hyperparameters.
Um
cuz then what do we sweep our sweeps?
Yeah.
But so there that and the quantile based
dressing that is like 30 like lower 30%
isn't like not too aggressive like so
yeah Gaussian process needs like some
data to get a good estimate. So like
aggressive early stopping like leads to
bad GP regression
uh that I have observed. So like it so
the the the safe zone and like low
quantile thresholding those are
necessary uh not not to be too
aggressive.
Can't we just like
But this is why is it quantile based on
score like this? Can't we just say like
if you're 30% worse than an existing run
that you like an existing run then it's
bad?
>> Like can't we do it based on the
existing data
>> that is being updated on existing data?
So in early sweeps
>> yeah that that is adaptive. So when you
see it
>> so it's just like a fe uh feeding that
like a quantile regression every uh with
the given set of data. So in early
sweeps that that score will be very low.
So there is very little thresholding but
as GP regression gets better
>> and hyperparameter gets better uh the
scores the observation we get uh uh gets
better so so that uh the thresholding
increases adaptively but still set to
like low 30%.
Okay. So, I don't understand how this
works then. Let me see.
>> Yeah, like uh
>> hang on. Maybe let me see if brain will
function today.
>> You got to like uh you got to quote
write CUDA kernel today.
>> Cuda kernels. Yeah.
>> See if we're gonna see if uh we're gonna
see if
Now, are you going to speak to Tanigra?
If that's good.
Um, I mean, if it means if he can match.
So if I write all these kernels and he's
and tiny is just like faster out of the
box with no downsides uh and I just like
yeah then totally
then I'll just be like hey uh meta like
Google you guys are morons
um this guy just beat your pants off. I
even went and wrote my own kernels and
he beat my pants. I will be very very
humble about it. Uh but I highly doubt
that happens.
doors will be on fire, I guess.
>> I mean, if that's actually the if that
is actually the thing that happens, then
but like these companies should just
like retire already.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, I guess they I guess that will
fully in my mind solidify their place as
retirement homes.
>> Yeah, they can buy a couple. But yeah,
going back to You're distracted. Yes.
Why? Why do I open this? Like this is
like I guess this is just like poisoning
my mind. Like I'm just thinking about
this constantly. I just open it
unconsciously.
>> All right.
>> I don't
>> I don't say that their LLMs are bad
compared to like how they should be,
man. I say that their LM are like bad at
the task that I'm doing. I actually like
LM are a way better optimized space in
general.
And I think that people are doing like
overly complicated but generally pretty
efficient stuff in that space.
>> All right. So this here
>> max of cost and epsilon and then it's
log. So
>> Mhm.
>> Let me see if I can understand this. So
what is epsilon here?
>> Uh that is just to prevent a numerical
error like a
>> so it's actually a very small epsilon.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So
max of cost. Okay. So it's going to be
log cost. Oh duh. It's called log C.
>> So it's A + B log C.
>> Yeah.
>> So and then you're telling me that this
looks
>> like that in in
>> Okay. So a so this is a right this this
value is a and then this shape this is
the log shape.
Uhhuh.
And you see that the curve is changing
right? So that means whenever every new
observation comes in uh not every so new
observations are taken into account when
that feeding happens which is when your
course suggests so when GP regression is
like being trained again that's the time
that like the lost curve is updated
uh so like like with every new
observation that look model is updated
And as the sweep goes on with better
data, that thresholding increases.
Yeah, like I I the in the the the code
in the proper RL like that hacky things
are to get that curve out. So I wanted
to see
that rectioing curve to see if it's
working as I intended.
Okay. And then these A and B. Okay. This
is so this is where this happens.
Minimize quantile loss.
Okay. I see.
So, and then the thing is these should
be fit conservatively, shouldn't they?
>> So, so that's where the like quantile
comes in
>> and then the roost is
>> quantile loss.
>> Uh-huh. So, so that quantile rose is
like a little bit different from the
like standard like mean squared error
and and that's where the quantile like
from the config comes in and that's set
to like three like lower 30%.
>> Lower 30%.
>> Oh, okay. That's it. It is. So, what
this is trying to do is
>> if you're in the bottom 30% of runs, go
away.
>> Go away. Yeah.
>> Okay, that's perfect.
>> Okay. So, then this is actually very
good. But what what is this doing then?
Cuz like
>> this this seems reasonable to me. This
does not.
>> Uh-huh.
Yeah. So like that's like when when you
you have
you have spend 120% more than the like
current par to like like current maximum
score
>> and then like you haven't still bit b it
then go away.
>> Well then why not just make this one
>> or actually it should be less than one
because there's going to be noise in
that curve.
Uh
I mean I could if this were 0.95 I would
agree with you completely.
>> Right. So if this were 0.95 we're like
we agree that this is like
>> the only way that you filter out good
runs with 0.95 with this. Um well I
guess it depends because when are you
using this? Like
how often like are you just applying
this every epoch?
>> What do you mean every uh uh
>> like
>> yeah it's it's being Yeah. Yeah.
Evaluated every
>> Okay. So let me explain something
because this I don't know if this is you
were thinking about this but your train
curves. Okay. So if you're thinking of
your train curves as this
>> right or this
or whatever
>> you know the train curves in RL look
weird sometimes you know you get like
this
>> like then this is all fine but what
happens
okay what happens when your train curves
look like this
>> jittery
>> which is what you always get right when
you sample
Yeah.
>> And then what happens is you get that
the parto point is here.
>> Mhm.
>> But then you know you get a point like
this for eval.
>> Yeah.
>> That's bad, right?
>> Okay.
>> So, and if we go look I think this would
have filtered like
>> if we go look at my soda run. Obviously,
if your thing is filtering my soda run,
it's bad, right? If you're say if your
if your hyperparam sweep would filter
out a soda run, then it's bad, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, let's go look at it. What would
have happened here? I'm pretty sure
you'll get you'll see it
>> cuz this is soda on neural MMO.
>> Mhm.
>> You see how much noise there is
in these curves?
>> Yeah.
It's
>> a huge amount of noise, right?
Mhm.
>> And then what we do is to get this final
to get a final evaluation point, we
always run extra,
>> remember?
>> Mhm.
>> And actually, look right there with the
extra at the end, we get a 9.05,
the last eval. Um, but like this is a
big problem
because you don't you're not going to
have like an accurate eval,
right?
>> Yeah, I agree.
>> So, you either you either have to
dramatically
reduce the sensitivity of this thing
or you have to get a smoothed like
accumul like basically you have to do
the smoothing in puffer li so that you
get the smoothed curve.
And then you're doing it on the smooth
curve instead of the uh the raw curve.
>> Mhm. Because even with 0 n5, you would
still filter this run out, right?
>> Likely. Yes.
>> Right here. Like right here. This would
be under 0 n5 of this mean value right
here. This run would get filtered.
>> right. Because you look at the bottom of
the purple zone.
>> No, no, no, no, no. Wait. So, so there
like the the reference is
uh let's say the your soda run has the
maximum cost, right? So, so that like
harding one kick off until it gets 120%
of the maximum
you see. So,
>> I see. Yes. Okay. Well, then you'll get
filtered out though.
>> Let me think.
So, so it won't get filtered out until
if if you are learning that
uh for the like same number of time step
time steps and if that run is like not
too slow so that it finishes around like
within 120% of the training then that
you you won't hit that like that wire
I think you still hit like
I mean if like this is not a sweep,
right? Obviously these runs are way too
big to be part of a sweep. This is 650
billion steps.
>> Um but if they were part of sweeps like
>> you would basically filter any new runs
out immediately.
>> What do you mean?
>> Okay, this one is like actually soda. So
it's like actually appreciably better.
But the the comparison threshold is
going to be the bottom of this zone, the
bottom of this purple shaded zone to the
mean right here.
So,
so, so there
>> it's not smooth.
>> You that comparison don't happen until
you have expand 120% of the training
budget.
>> Right? But if you're running a fresh
sweep and all your runs have this amount
of variance in them,
>> right? Like if all your runs have this
amount of variance, you make it very
very hard to expand to higher cost.
Uh
yes. But uh like when when your initial
run has has like run long enough
then that becomes the like the and 120%
of that uh cost that that uh duration
will be the reference point.
So unless the new training runs are
being trained until then.
>> Mhm.
>> And then yeah, you won't hit that
condition.
>> But you want them to be able to spend
more cost to get better, right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. But what I'm saying here is like
right now the comparison is already
disadvantaged. It's disadvantaged
differently for every environment just
purely based off of the variance in the
learning curve, right?
Different environments, different like
batch sizes are all going to give you
different amounts of variance.
And then what you have is you're saying
that it that the disadvantaged new run
has to be 1.05
max score better. But at 1.05, 5. First
of all, like this is impossible for
anything that's 01 normalized already.
>> But let's say that we were going to make
it 1.0. Even if you make it 1.0,
>> then if you have two curves that are
close to each other and you know you go
past, okay, let's say that this one was
only run for 450 billion steps, right?
As soon as I start going past it, my
run's going to get cut off because the
bottom of this zone, even though I'm
better, let alone if it were like a very
close difference, right? Um, it would
get cut off because the bottom of this
zone is less than the mean of this zone.
>> Uh, yeah, like I I agree with you on
that. Yes, one one.5
that is like too strict.
>> So, I mean, I think that ideally
I think that the largest value you would
ever want to have here would be like
one. And then the only time you would
ever want to have one would be if you
had like a perfect estimate, right?
>> If these curves were perfectly smooth,
if you just ignore the shaded zones and
these were the ground truths, then like
I think it works with one.
Um
>> so so let me like take two steps back.
So
>> well this is also it's 20 hang on I
misunderstood one thing I misunderstood.
So it's plus 20%. So then the comparison
point is going to be from like what like
over here to here right?
>> Uh
so so
that is the single value the upper bound
is the single value which is the like
the the whole duration of the sort run.
>> Yeah. So if the soda run ends here
>> then
say runs there.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's going to be okay. So if there
were no noise in your learning curve and
you set that coefficient to one, not
1.05, I agree that this is perfect. Um
because there is noise, I think that
this has to be handled. And
>> I'm trying to think how we handle this
>> like.9
>> we can do 0.9 and just hope that there
isn't 10% variance. I guess I think
realistically the best thing would be to
kind of be to do both and to just have a
smooth score estimate as well.
>> Uh yeah. So
and the smoothing can be handled within
the low cost model. Yeah.
>> Or
hang on. Does it have to be smooth or
can we just do
Because instead of taking the mean, we
get a whole bunch of samples every time,
right? So instead of like well I guess
it depends on the environment because
sometimes when you get logs like you
don't actually get very many of them
which is why you get this amount of
variance. I guess instead of having just
a smoothed mean we could just do like a
um like a one standard deviation like a
conservative estimate like hey this run
could be you know as good as this.
I think that there should be some type
of smoothing or some type of fit though
so that we ensure that we're not killing
off good runs because of this noise. And
then you change that coefficient to
either one or maybe a little lower than
one. And I think it's good.
>> So there like the simplest approach
would be just uh like doing running
average like the 50 or 100 data points.
>> Mhm.
uh or is it too arbitrary or
anyway or or we can get like standard
deviation of like the last like 50 or
last 100 runs so that we don't have to
keep every like score and then
>> yeah I think there's some sort of
there's some sort of like
>> not over complicate it but some sort of
like basic noise reduction thing that we
should do. Um.
>> Mhm.
>> Definitely. Definitely.
>> Yeah. Like a So, so keep the like last
100 data points, get the mean and
standard deviation from there.
>> Yeah. And then test this on both
>> like really short environments to make
sure that like by doing this you haven't
screwed up really short running
environments like pong and then test it
on like some more longunning
environments as well. And then I think
>> yeah that's where like I've tested on
Tetris and like Tetris
is it seems to work. So
>> Tetris has this like exponential score
curve right?
>> Uh
not not exponential.
>> Tetris like take off all of a sudden and
then just go up like mad.
>> Oh I've I've normalized it.
>> I claimed that. Yeah. So, so that that
the performance
is yeah I the maximum is around one not
necessarily one sharp but yeah
I I attached the like Tetris figure on
the PR have a look
>> did I did I miss that all right my bad
let me see
>> that's Tetris
>> oh I thought this was breakout as well
>> hey
>> uh the one yeah one above that is
breakout out. So I attach it too.
>> I think that would work very well in
population based learning.
>> Is this
>> something like PB2 or PB2? Uh it's BA.
I'm I'm just joining in. I've been
listening for a while. Hey,
>> welcome. You are on stream for
reference.
>> Uh
>> oh, that's good to know.
>> Okay.
I see what this norm.
Yeah. Yeah. So, I was probably only
running this portion. But when I was
running it before, I was only running it
for this long here.
Like this portion.
>> You can't see my cursor.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Like up to 600ish seconds. So, it looked
exponential to me cuz I didn't get the
other portion of the curb.
>> Okay. and and score some change and I
the Tetris got difficult. So now it's it
looks more reasonable to me. So
>> okay I mean if you have this
>> and you see
>> no
>> uh
I think that's the only then the only
thing I have right is that at the very
least that 1.05 05 should be one and
then there should be like some form of
smoothing or conservatism on it because
it'll filter like that's going to filter
way too aggressively
cuz basically what you've done here
right is like so compare you have this
quantile here
>> so you draw like you know the lower
bound
do I not have p the epic pen on here
whatever so
I thought I had the annot ation tool.
But anyways, you have like this lower
bound, which if you overlap these two
graphs, like you're really not filtering
very aggressively at all with lower 30%.
Right.
>> Right.
>> And then you have this really freaking
aggressive
>> um like end like a better soda run
thing. Yeah. And like that's weird to me
cuz I think that this this is basically
a free win. This like lower 30%. This is
just like filter out a good chunk of
time.
Uh, and you might even be able to make
this a little more aggressive like
because this is really conservative,
right? Like in my mind, we could filter.
Okay, hang on. Heck,
can I just paste images in? Is that a
thing?
I can. Perfect.
Okay. So, right now this looks like
this.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. So, like, you know, this
could even be,
you know, this could even be like a like
a this thing, right? Like you could
filter quite a bit more aggressively.
But then what you're doing is if I put a
point over here,
>> you're going to filter out anything.
Yeah. Your filter I think it goes to
like
your filter just like goes to here
immediately, right? Like plus 20%. And
then you have like a hard
>> No, no, no, no. It It's like 5%. Like
you have you spent 20% more then like
give me 5% more.
>> Okay. But we are you're already above
the perf on this task.
>> And if this were if this were 01 on like
a percentile based task,
>> then you prevent
>> Yeah.
So this is in my mind this is just like
crazy aggressive.
>> Uh I why do you even need to have these
two conditions at all?
>> Uh because like now when I see the
breakout then like when I see that like
uh.9
like 6.97ish
uh runs with 100 seconds 120 seconds
they they drive me crazy. So
>> I see
>> like to me those those are like not
informative run.
>> I see.
>> So
>> okay takes much longer. So yeah that
that you have to do something on the
high cost regime too
>> because once you have already the
environment
>> okay let me think.
feel like it's more of what do we do
with the bad runs.
Um because if we reuse them and started
from scratch and we are far in the run,
it might be having a lot of costs. But
if a bunch of these or all of these are
resumed from um some of the currently
running runs, then you you essentially
checkpoints, then you'd have pretty good
performance.
>> This isn't population based like that.
This is this is protein which is
Gaussian process based. It uses the same
sort of genetic approach on top of uh it
uses a sort of like Gaussian process
guided genetic thing but it's not the
type of algorithm that you just run a
ton of different runs in parallel like
that. Um, I mean that's really
>> the only like time you really do that is
when you're optimizing for
>> like really high hardware uh high
hardware availability which is not our
main use case.
>> Um, but even with only a few runs, it
would increase efficiency to um better
utilize these runs that are being thrown
out and then restarted from scratch. Um,
>> well, we're using these runs to to train
the Gaussian process.
Right. Right. So, you're using all of
the data, not only the final score.
>> We're using a down training curve.
>> Yeah.
>> You get a few
>> data comes out of
>> is it like five data points now, K?
>> Yeah.
>> So, yeah, you just like you take you
just take five points on the learning
curve. And I mean it's the same thing
because it's the same hypers with the
exception of um uh the total time steps
>> time steps.
>> Yeah. So it gets a down sample version
of the curve and that's used to train
the GP.
>> All of these dots are essentially runs.
>> Yes.
>> It looks quite wasteful. I mean with a
puffer li is fast but having that many
runs look looks very wasteful.
>> How do you tune like 20 hyper
>> parameters? The environment is fast. So
>> like how do you tune like 20 I mean I'm
not aware of anything that does like
that just can tune a ton of
hyperparameters with substantially fewer
runs.
>> I mean that there's no great solution to
the problem. Um but but large
environments multifile
>> like I don't have intuition as to how
many data points it would take when you
have like 20 hyperparameters right
>> yeah and it depends also if
hyperparameters interact with each other
>> um like some tree might help with this
>> some some do um and and this is
optimizing how many hyperparameters
>> whatever puffer has 20ish like 20ish
>> yeah 20 plus
>> and yeah the the 500 is like I ran a
like a pretty like large three but uh
normally it's like around 400 and it
seems to get us good runs in like 100
runs or so like we start to see like
pretty good runs after 100 runs. So
Gausian process is pretty good.
>> I have not found anything better. Like
all the PBT based things, they
the PBT based things kind of like cheat
by combining multiple different runs
into one on the same plot and they just
use a ton of hardware. Um cuz they just
launch a ton of stuff in parallel. Like
that fundamentally can't be efficient.
you're kind of just doing a like
intelligent asha at that point like
asynchronous happing. Um this is more
sequential. So in fact you should
require fewer runs which should be more
hardware efficient and less wall clock
efficient
>> um synchronous asha. Yeah I I know what
you mean. Um but but Pvt has shown quite
great performance when the environment
is very long to train. Um
>> well no that's because they use a ton of
hardware,
>> right?
>> Um I mean even even with only a few
sample like asynchronous runs um having
the ability to come back um like kill a
run and then use a checkpoint from
another run makes it efficient. But I
understand your your point of view where
um the processes the B processes has
less data to sample from. So of course
you'll get less quality in each new
sample.
>> Um
>> the other thing I
>> talking about the reuse of the
checkpoints.
>> So you you end up creating something
where your final model is an artifact of
the sweep itself because you chain
together different hyperparameters. If
you're going to do the thing where
you're restarting checkpoints and
setting the hyperparameters like
changing hyperparames midrun, then your
final model becomes an artifact of the
sweep rather than something that is
easily reproducible where you can just
have your set of hyperparameters and do
the full run from scratch. I really
don't like that property of it. It's
like very very bad for science.
>> Yeah, it's um it it also means that it
biases towards evil. uh it bi biases the
runs towards evil because it's
essentially learning the evil score. So
if if the evaluation has a different
technique or different metric um it's
it's teaching itself. Um but for for
some kind of environment like neural MMO
uh it might create some kind of new sot
results because of
>> it could for sure I think you need a ton
of hardware
>> like
>> the neural MMO result this is 650 bill
>> 650 bill
>> 650 billion steps.
>> Yes.
>> Yes. That's 1300 years of games.
>> 13,000 years of games.
>> That is a lot of steps.
>> Um,
>> and consumer GPU. So,
>> yeah,
>> that's 64090s each for those runs.
>> I read that you're running it on on the
tiny
>> Yeah, I got stuff on the tiny boxes that
are up behind me.
>> Tiny box
>> with the 40s or the 50s?
>> 6x4090s.
The new ones, the new boxes they have
are 4x5090s
>> and uh or the pro one they have this 8x
>> 5090. I might get one of those. We'll
see.
>> Yeah. So like three is already
prohibitive for like Euro MMO.
>> I the only thing I'm not sure behavior
here. I think that you're kind of right,
but like
>> it just depends on what type of ends you
have, right? Like how much do you care
about having it fully fully optimized?
Well, so very optimized like I'm I tend
to be more interested in the like left
side of the par curve like give me the
good runs as fast as possible. So like
those high cost and like like saturated
runs are like less informative to me.
Yeah, because if I were to just so if
you were to literally just do um here
you could just do even the simplest fit
you could come up with, right? Which is
like this
that cuts out probably 80 90% of the
training, right?
>> Uh wait, wait, like what's that curve?
>> If I just do this.
>> Yeah, I cut out like that's probably
half. If I draw it here, I probably cut
out like 80 90% of the training time.
>> Yes.
>> But then like for drive, they really
care about that like they really really
care about the uh the terminal or like
the uh the best behavior, right?
>> Yeah. So, so like, so there like my I
keep saying that but then like score
there really doesn't do good for that
kind of optimization. Like you have to
have like different score metric to
really like drive GP toward the best
runs.
>> Well, okay, here's an idea, Kyouong. Um,
>> you can you link me this plot? Actually,
here's the plot that I'd like you to
link me if you have it. Can you link me
the plot that shows uh the creation time
of the experiment versus the score or
the Perf?
>> Uh so it's like colorcoded there kind of
but I will
>> it see.
>> So because what I'm thinking here is
it's possible that maybe we just have it
expanding too quickly, right? Like maybe
what we can do is we can have it so that
it fills in this curve. um much more
consistently. And then
>> so so wait uh can you can you look at
the like petric curve? So like
>> yes
>> the the one on the Yeah,
>> this one's way more obvious,
>> right? So
So you need some like time to like GPS
need some time to run to come up with a
good hyperparameter.
>> Yeah. So basically what I'm thinking
here Kyouong is maybe we have it
expanding too quickly
where
>> basically right we should we should have
it fitting this GP if it's going to run
bad experiments stop running bad
experiments that take a lot of time
>> and like sort of fill this like I think
it would be cool if over time you kind
of just fill this chunk in more
consistently
um rather than having to run like
if you
I guess the thing the thing that's
happening right now is if you run uh if
you run 200 experiments
here
>> Mhm.
>> Let me show you. I think we're just
allocating our compute wrong.
Welcome Hyper.
I think we're allocating the the compute
wrong. So
if I if you run let's say that you get a
PTO front uh that looks like if you run
200 experiments right now you probably
get a parto front that looks like this
right
>> which like a little bit below
>> and then if you run 500 it looks like
this.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. It will move left and not.
>> Yeah. Well, what we should have is we
should get a PTO front instead. If we
run 200 that looks like this.
And then if we run 500, we get a PTO
front that looks like that maybe.
>> Yeah, that is ideal,
>> I guess. Well, it depends, right? You're
what you're trying to do, right? Like
cuz this gets you a better run faster,
but it just wastes so much time.
Oh, but wait, actually, h we might be
able to just have it be strictly better
because these runs these runs just take
so much freaking time.
Wait, is this run? Hang on. Let me
actually see something
cuz you linked me. These plots are after
you've already done this early stopping
thresholding, right?
>> Yes.
>> So yeah, even with this thresholding,
it's still wasting all this compute.
>> And it's much better than before,
>> right?
>> I mean, like I guess like it would have
saved like half of compute already,
>> right? And then but the thing is the
only way that this point even exists
here because this is below this filter
is that it was like before it knew how
to it knew anything it was already
running super long experiments for some
reason. Yes.
And and so so that's where the the hard
stuff like came uh because like uh the
adaptive like quantile based dressing
had increase very slow but like hard
stop is already there.
>> So like
>> Yeah, I see. Because you're you're
trying to basically stop it from running
really long experiments before it has
any business doing so. M
>> yeah and and at that time like
>> the the only reference point I have is
the parade of front so far
and and like just based on that 120%
like just don't go over that without
like a very good reason to do so.
So,
>> well, I
>> I think that if you were to put that at
>> I think it's just it's probably the
issue is it's such a big disconnect
right now because
this is like this is like super safe in
my mind, right? Like this is
>> yes I think it's conservative.
>> Yeah, this is very conservative but then
the other one is super aggressive.
super aggressive but uh
I I
see
>> and then the safe zone
>> because
So that's because like I was mainly
testing on breakout which happened so
fast and then
>> yeah like
>> Gaussian process like that that quantile
based dressing was already like catching
like many
>> well it ideally the conservatism should
basically let it learn like hey the the
threshold here should be zero.
>> So,
uh yes, like it's
can probably do without safe turn maybe.
>> I also I'm kind of wondering like if
this is the good fit in the first place.
So quantilebased thresholding here.
I'm trying to think if we cannot just
like you know draw our line.
like draw under the parto front like
this. This becomes the filter.
>> I tried that like I tried to make a
filter based on par curve but that was
too aggressive.
>> So GP did not run very well. So
>> it's hard based on parto points like
anything based on just like the
individual PTO points is very sensitive.
I found that out when I was developing
protein.
>> Yeah. So, so there like I this is like
the step back version from that and
that's not I could not mess with GP
process.
So that's where like uh the save John
also came in. So
yeah like
>> decent step I'd say. Um I mean I think
that this here this portion here this is
definitely better than what we have now.
Oh, which portion
>> like this like log quantile this where
is it? This chunk of the if statement.
>> Uh where is it?
>> All right, this thing.
This is definitely better than what we
had before. Or this thing. Then this
thing is super aggressive.
But you're saying like the thing is that
this thing
>> it's going to get because this thing is
so conservative. This is going to like
if you don't have this thing, you let a
bunch of runs through
and like longer runs through.
>> Yeah. Especially during early pace when
GP is not that good. So
that's kind of like a like
safety net. It's not safety net. But
it's weird to me because like so it
doesn't
>> it will not keep the point right for um
it doesn't actually expand the threshold
going forward unless the point is parto
right Kim
uh
well
it the the the
candidates are sampled from paro Yes,
but especially during early it it's not
necessarily give us a like good results.
>> Okay, fair.
>> So, so that's that happens like like
within first 50 runs or so.
>> Yeah. So, what basically you end up with
with this red curve
very early
and then the whole curve just gets
pushed up over time.
But it's very inefficient.
>> Yeah, it's it's rising sori. Yes.
>> I mean, we could just The other thing
you could play with, I suppose, is I
haven't really played with the expansion
rate of protein a bunch. Like, it could
be that it's just pushing to longer runs
too fast.
>> Oh. So, so that's where that's where
like I'm like
>> doing parto pruning at least.
>> Wait, but then the other thing is
but like what is the first run that you
launch? Like is the default run super
long? Because if the default run is
super long, then yeah, you're going to
get like a a pretty good starter curve.
So, you're already going to push through
front end.
>> Yeah, the start start is already the
like the default run. So in case of
Tetris that will be around uh 1,200.
>> Yeah. So it gets already like let's say
it's this point here.
>> Mhm.
>> Be like a decent default.
>> Yeah.
>> Um
>> but but GP is not that good at that
time. So the early 20 30 uh runs will be
like very noisy. So
you got to stop them. So, so that's why
you see dark blue dot around like a
1,400.
Well, maybe
does this thing need to just be more
Wait,
aggressive then like this early stop
threshold because
the quantile based?
>> Yeah.
Uh
I don't know like now we are talking
about meta hyperparameters.
>> Yeah. And this is the annoying bit.
So that yeah like I'm I'm not too happy
with like what I have now. But that's
that's better than
>> Oh, this is this portion is definitely
better. So this chunk here is definitely
better. This portion here has a really
obnoxious side effect. I think that if
you just if you change this to like
N or 0.95 and added some smoothing.
>> Oh yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I I
agree with that. Like that there can be
made better. But this is going to I
think this I think that doing that is
going to mess up your results on these
>> because it's going to let too many runs
through and then the really conservative
filter is not going to catch them.
>> Oh, wait. Can you speak uh tell me
again?
>> So, because I think what's going to
happen is I'm gonna tell you to fix
this. You're gonna go change this
>> point.
>> Yeah. And then
very early on in training, this filter
is going to be too conservative and it's
going to let runs through that look like
this. And then you're going to get like
a bunch of extra wasted points here.
>> Uh that's the like trade off your
willing to like
>> that is the trade-off with the current
model, right?
>> Yeah.
But hey, I mean, at least you're more
aware of this now. Like we need to have
like the good outcome of this is that
you get uh you do get more expensive
runs over time that like fine-tune
performance. I mean, I think I think
that realistically even on something
like Breakout, right, where you like
even on something like Breakout where
you're running these 100 second
experiments.
>> Mhm.
>> All you have to do to prevent that
forever, right?
So, uh, with like
Okay, maybe with 1.0 O or something at
the very least. But I think that there's
a formulation under which all you have
to do to prevent that from happening
forever is let's say that you get one,
you just need to get one run that scores
that gets max score basically. Um
>> Mhm.
>> Like if you get right here, if this one
if this at 40 seconds if you get max
score then everything else after that is
nullled, right?
>> Yeah.
So then anything it tries to run like
20% more than 40. So by 48 seconds
everything everything 48 seconds or
longer gets printed.
>> Uh no like so I saw that and there like
in the quote like I made that the max
score like does not decrease. It only
can increase
>> the max score.
>> So yeah, like when you go to the code.
Yeah. So like I saw that parto can
change pretty drastically.
So like uh go to sweep uh sweep.pai.
Spencer says that uh selfplay hacked the
world. See a second.
Uh
target cost ratio. Yeah, look for target
cost ratio.
And wait, not it's not target cost
ratio. Uh wait uh
yeah I I made I tweaked that part but uh
see
uh upper coast threshold. Yeah, search
for upper coast threshold.
Yeah, there. So, so that's that's the
where you draw the line in the sand
and yeah in it comes from print uh par
front and then it it can only increase
but not decrease. Yeah, it's super hecky
one.
>> Why would you do that?
>> Part also
yeah can mess up with GP regression
pretty fast. So I want it to be
conservative there.
>> But wait, why would you
what is this used for?
>> So So that's that's where the like hard
stop gets.
>> Oh,
>> yeah. There.
>> Why would you not just use
>> Why would this
>> Why would this not just be the cost of
the current like the current uh like
highest cost burrito point?
So like when what I observed is like yes
the parto front
got like a pushed left
suddenly and then
I I in breakout like I I saw there are
like a shoe for fast runs like have you
seen that that like solves breakout and
like 20 or 25 seconds.
>> Uh, so that's typically the value
function clipping coefficient hack
thing, right? Like the really low value
function clip.
>> So, so there like some of them like it
runs like 4 billion SPS like soft break
>> 4 million. Yes. Like I I I have seen
like few of them like when things are
aligned it seems to be that way. and
then it solves breakout in 20 seconds
and then it starts best of all the sweep
especially if you set the threshold
based on that. So yeah, after seeing
that like several times like I I want
that like upper like threshold of bound
to be
>> like moving slow and like not increase
because yeah it it so
>> yes there are pros but the con is like
it can suddenly start to mess up with GP
regression.
And
>> it shouldn't. Well,
>> but this is a threshold that is applied
to this is applied like to an online
tour run. This is not applied as a
filter to the suggestions, right?
>> It is applied to the run that's running.
Yes. Not the filter.
>> Okay. That's weird then that that messes
stuff up. I the thing that I'm getting
concerned about is I think that you
could be overfitting the sweep heristics
to like a couple of environments. Um
>> yes
>> and this is like something I noticed
when I was developing protein very very
difficult to like you know keep in mind
that you can have M's that have this
like like longtail behavior where you
really care about the last bit of PF.
You have M's where you don't necessarily
care about the last bit of PF. pretty
much all M's you're going to care about
actually getting a good burrito front at
the very least. Um I think
yeah I think that the best thing for you
to do with this is first of all please
actually like write out like if you can
just put like a bullet point for each
like what are the heruristics that you
currently have in this thing and
because I because I would like to know
because I think there are a couple
things that have slipped by me here and
Yeah, I think then this like this
expansion factor thing and like how do
we deal with slow expansion to longer
and longer runs. That's going to be the
key
>> the key thing
>> and it should not be like some complete
heristic hack. You know, originally when
I was developing protein, I wanted to
somehow formulate the sweep itself as an
optimization problem in which like
you're spending budget to gain
information, right? into information or
gaining is like expanding the sweep, but
I couldn't figure out how to do it that
way.
>> Um,
>> that is a very basian thing to do.
>> Well, yeah. And there's like these
acquisition functions which they do.
They kind of try to do that with carbs,
but then the thing is you actually go
look at the Gaussian processes and
they're basically pure noise. So like
anything, especially the variance
estimates are basically pure noise.
Okay. I think though for the time being
the thing that you the actionable thing
for the time being is this is too
aggressive. make this more conservative
so that we know that we're not going to
break stuff because uh for reference my
goal is in the next couple of weeks as
soon as I have a stable version of
puffer 4 I want to start getting the
constellation sweeps in and ideally
>> so ideally you know I want to use the
current version of uh like of protein
with all your optimizations in there and
you know if on a couple environments we
find something where it clearly breaks
that's fine and like we can redo
experiments. But ideally like we I want
to have like a very good understanding
of what tweaks need to be made because I
want to have like and by then we also we
want to have the thing stable, right?
Because that's going to be the clearest
test of the sweep algorithm as well. Um
>> Mhm.
>> you know because like the curves that we
get out of that are going to be we can
do like a 100,000 experiments uh on
that.
>> Yeah. as well. And then we definitely
want
>> So I I know like that it will save a ton
of compute for sure. Yeah.
>> Yeah, it would definitely save but we
also want to make sure that we don't
screw up asic behaviors, right? Like we
want to make sure that for instance that
whatever we're running, we don't have
like solves breakout super fast, solves
pong super fast, solves G2048 super
fast, but then we go try it and like on
the driving results of constellation, it
caps at 99%. Right. when that
environment we really care right like
stuff like that or like on neural MMO
for instance because you know this
threshold was applied and there was
noise in the curve neural MMO doesn't do
any like right we want to make sure we
avoid that stuff as much as possible
>> let me download this
>> yeah like for duro MMO like uh if we are
to
uh like
>> oh this is hilarious This
>> Yeah, shoot perfume for sure.
>> That's insane,
Huh? Self play is like uh
>> holy
I guess.
>> Uh Spencer, since you found that, you
should put that in an article. That is
awesome. Save that for when you release
the uh like there should be a selfplay
blog from that. That's awesome.
That's freaking awesome.
Yeah. So there like for neuro MMO like
uh
>> wait
>> it will be solvable.
>> I didn't even catch that. This makes the
opponent lose a life.
>> Holy hell.
>> I didn't even see that part. Whoa.
>> Why? What happened?
it like I thought that it just dropped
it eventually. No, it somehow it phases
the puffer through the wall and it
actually makes the opponent lose a life
in a way where it's like there's no
counterplay.
Uh, okay.
Huh.
Yeah. Like so like these agents are
really cool like a beta testers. They
will like test to death.
>> That's [ __ ] crazy, dude.
It doesn't need to come up with this
solution to win against the Sander
Deontebot. Yeah,
I don't know how it even came up with
that. That's nuts.
>> Book fix time.
I almost don't want I like I honestly
don't even want to fix that bug. That's
like too cool.
and make an argue uh the argument to ri
it versus fix it. So
>> I mean honestly like putting that one
versus the abbronty like versus the
scripted bot
>> and just be like you know this is a demo
of selfplay the selfplay broke the game
in a way that no human would ever find.
>> That's crazy.
The superhuman bot has a 100% win rate
against any
>> against literally anything.
That's crazy.
>> Okay. Uh, anything else, K?
>> No, but yeah. Yeah. You keep saying
drive then like uh I keep saying Yeah.
like the score metric should be changed
for drive. Well, but isn't this the same
for any of the games that have like
percentage based win rate?
>> So,
>> it would be the same for like Connect
Four. It'd be the same for Triple Triad.
It'd be the same for chess when we have
that for Go.
there like
so can like
uh be used instead
>> only if you're assuming that it's a like
a competitive selfplay formulation.
Anything that has a solve rate, dude.
Like literally anything that has a solve
rate here. Tower climb will have this
problem too, right? Anything that has a
solve rate
>> will be uh like percentage based system.
>> Okay. So there like what's the metric
look like there?
>> Completion rate.
>> Completion.
>> Yeah. Like did you complete the map?
That's the completion rate.
>> And like it has all sorts of different
maps. They're easy maps and hard maps,
right? So if you're if you get 90%
completion rate, that's pretty good. But
like it actually matters to get higher
and higher completion rates.
I mean, what's it's like getting 95 or
like 99 on a test almost, right? It's
like the last you can't ignite
every M to not have percentage-based
rates. It's like a very common and
natural scoring pattern for a lot of
different M's.
>> I see. Then yeah probably I will
I will just go for like uh.9%
uh.9
>> that's a good thing to start with
simil metric and if n have that
percentage score base
>> and fine with like longer runs then
>> yeah
you you get Well, that's that's the
tradeoff we make. Yeah.
Yeah. That's that that that that's
another problem, let's say, that like a
sweep uh cannot handle for now.
>> For now. And there will be a way a way
around this. It's just going to take
some work.
>> I got to get back to fixing this kernel
so that we can actually have this
>> the speed to do all these things. Um,
but yeah, let's keep discussing this
over well, whenever you have time to
work on it. Um, because this is going to
be the sweep stuff is just so important.
And I know how fiddly it is cuz I went
through this exact same process of like
figuring out, oh shoot, some
environments have percentile scoring,
some of them have, you know, log type
curves, some are linear. It's a pain.
>> Yeah. So like uh let's reit that and I
will make a quick fixes that I can do
right now test again and certainly it
will be better than before. So yeah
let's start from there.
>> Cool.
Okay thanks. I will get back to colonel
dev.
I don't think I have any more PRs to
look at right now.
Hi F1.
>> So yeah mining
>> back to the CUDA mines.
>> That's cool.
I don't really want the laziness or the
functional nature necessarily, but if
it's fast, it's fast.
But we will see
he's caris with the jack's back end. No.
All
right, let me grab a
refill on my coffee. Let me use the
restroom real quick and then we will get
back to this ridiculous CUDA kernel for
what is a very simple operation that has
a really obnoxious gradient. I'll be
right back.
Well, let me turn the uh the new flag
lights on cuz they're kind of cool in
the spotlight.
We got these installed over the weekend.
Freaking Discord messages.
Make sure there's nothing I have to
answer right away.
All right.
Get the desktop audio again and
figure out why gradient is wrong.
Okay. So this is
elementwise everything
Keeps the war literally right there.
Oops. You see them all? Two tiny boxes.
Bunch of individual boxes.
They're all right behind me. This is the
puffer training facility.
out out index
gradient out
index times inverse RMS right
minus
wait. The gradient with respect to the
weight is just this, right?
equals zero.
Okay. Okay. And then we just do float.
W
G
I still see templates
for now, man.
For now.
probably will be eliminated.
It kind of depends because literally all
you're saving with these templates, I
believe, is um you're saving like two
casts.
You're not even saving the cast. I think
you're saving two copies. Maybe
might be worth it. We'll see.
E X I
X I S What is S?
Yeah, Discord's discord.gg/puffer
GG/puffer.
Missing division by H. That would be
completely stupid, wouldn't it?
Also, your indexing is completely
broken. Well, that's expected.
Oh yeah, the Okay.
Yeah, the weight of Kim is wrong
completely.
I'm going to just try this out of the
box to see if this does anything. I'm
not particularly hopeful,
but this is a fairly common kernel.
Oh yeah. Let's try this one first.
This is the slow version.
Try the slow version first.
Uh this will not surprise me actually if
this one is correct because
Yeah, this one would not surprise me if
this one is correct.
the block per vector version above.
Something is ungodly slow.
It change my signature without
rad.
stupid thing should not change my
function signatures.
That's just um that's an include
missing, right?
you know which one should be the
starting point. You are never going to
catch up with the number of streams I
do, so you should probably just watch
the live ones. And uh if you're looking
for formal material, then you should
check my guides here. Like if you're
looking for something to work through,
the best use of your time is depending
if you're very new this one or if you're
just looking for RL like working through
this will be the best use of time.
And other than that, you just watch the
uh whatever is currently the live stream
because that's what I'm doing at the
moment.
These are not like produced pieces of
content, right? These are just this is
what I'm doing on a day-to-day basis for
dev for puffer.
Want to get something to hack on? Yeah,
the guy will take you through that.
Invert. I've created a fanatic.
My gosh.
Does this make sense? Reinterpret cast
I actually don't know if this one is
fine, but uh it should not screw up our
test either way for a colonel we don't
even know is correct.
So, let's not spend more time on it
until we actually know whether this is
even any good.
It seems weird to me that epsilon
doesn't show up somewhere in the
gradient as well, right?
Oh, maybe it does actually cuz it's
Yeah, you have the cached inverse RMS
term.
But probably that's it.
Just for the hell of it, let's try this
one.
H this has
don't need to include uh
included.
That's stupid.
and let's see if I can understand in the
meantime if I want to contribute to
puffer liib any ML related math. Uh what
I'm doing here at the moment is I am
mostly failing to remember my CS231N.
You'll pretty much just follow the RL
guide on on Twitter. It has like my RL
guide will take you through all of the
things that you need and it like it will
direct you to everything you need as
well. So I guess that one's probably in
this one's in programming in ML. Yeah,
because it assumes as a prerec.
Where's T 231N?
Yeah, Stanford's 231N. Literally between
these do two blog posts though, you have
all my best advice.
See
this is saying that I missed
wait
out inverse RMS
out invms
I don't think that was supposed to be
there either. Right.
I go say rad index
wg
invar mass minus
x
thumb sum inverse
over h.
I actually don't see this over h though.
view.
I don't see where this over age. Hang
on.
Let me try something.
I wouldn't be surprised that it ends up
being this stupid thing.
I don't think there is a division by H
there.
I actually don't see how there could
Okay.
Yeah. No, there's that produces
Okay. Yeah. No, there's that produces massive massive brad. So there is got to
massive massive brad. So there is got to
be either there's a division by h or
something is missed which is like the
worst nightmare situation because now
it's like I don't know if the math is
wrong or the code is
Add weight
float red out
that maybe I misinterpreted the
original.
Ah, hang on because
xw.
Yeah, there's definitely no division by
h in here
yeah, so this is no longer a code
problem. This is a math problem.
I don't know why I didn't think of using
like auto diff on the or symbolic diff.
Let me see what was different here.
So
Oh, it's completely different here,
isn't it?
Or is it not?
Try something.
What is the difference between these
two?
Let me run it first to actually because
I like it's not worth wasting time if
it's wrong. Right.
Let me see if the math is mapping.
Uh and I also have to fix
this chunk here.
here. Still 0.2 off
which is like even closer.
Okay,
let's go back to this and let's actually
try to understand the math because I
think
I think at this point it is mostly a
question of
the math.
So wait sum let me go look at the the
symbolic version here
sum of 2 ai
2 * n
equals
we have 2 ai over 2 N
uh this is RMS=
A I over N RMS. mess
suggestion. I'm trying to figure out
what the heck is wrong. if it's the math
because it could be that the math like
it could just be that the the math is
wrong, not the implementation, right?
It's like not there's like not a bug
with the code. It's just I'm
implementing the wrong thing.
If I could just find
gradient.
They have the gradient in this. I
wonder.
How's there a weight matrix? It should
be a weight vector.
My lips got platform. I had no idea,
man. Didn't try it.
This is what I want is they actually
have colonels for this [ __ ]
I would really like to find the code for
this if I can.
Launch general.
Okay, so these are just the launchers.
I think so. Right. Isn't this the actual
colonel?
times diff all reduce sum oh yeah yeah
this is okay so for it's in the cuda h
file for some reason
so it stands to reason that this one
would be in here.
Uh
now the question is are we actually
going to be able to figure out the math
from Yes.
So, I mean, we found the code,
but uh
Yeah, someone had Exactly. Right. It's
like Well, [ __ ]
You know, I'm honestly thinking going
forward.
I'm learning so much by by doing this
though, right? Because if this is the
level of engineering it takes, like
if this is the level of engineering it
takes to make an RMS norm fast or
whatever, like here,
do you think that the people who wrote
this
were thinking like at all about actually
implementing this operation to be fast?
No, they were writing like a few lines
of PyTorch and just testing different
[ __ ] out. So like if you actually
approach architecture design from the
sense of like well what is easy for us
to make super fast and then you know you
kind of realize that a lot of
architectures end up doing very
similarly when matched in flops. You can
probably get very very far just by
understanding that. Right.
And I did not h I did not have a big
enough appreciation for this because I
forgot about the horror that cross terms
introduced and stuff like that, right?
Like yeah, any sets of like elementwise
gates or whatever, not a huge deal.
Those are pretty easy kernels to write,
but anything that's going to introduce
cross terms like this, you'd better have
a damn good reason for doing,
right? Because if this if this were not
something introducing cross terms,
right? Right? If this were just like
elementwise divide by I don't know
square root or something that's like
that's an easy kernel, right?
And then also this introduces additional
synchronization requirements.
Like I'm honestly wondering if like I
should do some architecture work after
this because
Like I don't know, can we just like um I
want to go read that like uh that tiny
recurrent network paper or whatever.
I don't know. Can you just like
come up with some matrix multiply based
very easy to implement uh very intensive
like operations
with some nonlinearities? I don't know
cuz basically all you're trying to do is
come up with like some arithmetically
intensive expressive operations that are
easy to implement. Right?
Most of deep learning just boils down to
you're doing some mat moles with some
nonlinearities in one way or another.
And like the researchers are never
thinking about this at all, right? The
researchers are comparing metrics that
frankly don't even matter that much most
of the time,
right? Like whoopdedoo. Your thing
converges in 20% fewer steps, but is
going to be a complete and utter
nightmare to implement to be anywhere
near, you know, within 20% of the speed
of the other one. It'll probably be 10%
of the speed of the other one.
Uh Jess, this is the crazy kernel Nvidia
has for RMS norm backwards.
Matrix math. Yes. So matrix math is
always the best option because the chips
are designed to do mat moles. Like
that's all the tensor cores do is they
do matt moles. So as soon as you're not
doing matt moles, the hardware no longer
helps you at all.
Quick question, why? Because we need RMS
norm to not be slow.
Can I just figure it out from this like
Compute dx,
dy,
It's so freaking hard to even figure out
the math from this though, dude.
Why is their kernel so whack?
Um, well, some of it is understandable
because like there are multiple
synchronization points to do this thing
fast.
And I think they're also they're
supporting like too many things in one
piece of code. Like I think this
technically supports a fused ad with it
as well.
I literally just need the gradient
written out for me.
The annoying thing about this
I don't think there's any way for me to
easily use this.
I can just get a working version. I can
optimize the hell out of it.
And I actually want to know like the
naive kernel. I want to know how it
compares to torches.
Completely wrong. Okay, go back to this.
We just have to need we just need to be
precise about this thing. Like there's
some very small math error most likely.
Thank you.
I have the forward pass. Correct. The
forward pass did not take very long.
Let me see if I give it the uh cuz you
know it probably is going to just keep
doing the math wrong but maybe it can
pull out the math from this.
Let me make sure I get it the right one
though.
Uh, this doesn't look like it has the
math in it, right?
This is What the heck is this then?
Yes, this actually has the
implementation in it.
BP regressions on score is uniform
space.
Actually
BP regressions on score. Is it on
uniform space?
It would not work at all if we were
doing uniform.
Unless is it scaled as it could be
scaled uniform space, right?
file. Okay. I think I experimented with
that already though, Kyouong.
Cuz the issue is it's not lo you don't
want log scale, right, for the
percentiles. you want logic scale and
you don't want to have to like configure
That
This I wouldn't be surprised if it's
able to get right now because
uh I've given it the Nvidia kernel. So,
it's literally just having to like
meticulously pull out logic.
And if this isn't right, then we're
going to start looking at other stuff
like did I populate buffers correctly?
It's like slightly closer still. Okay,
let me go look at the forward pass
buffers.
But the only thing we store is this,
right?
Inorm buff float.
Let's see how we could possibly be
messing this one up.
Okay. So, I mean, they're both freaking
wrong now,
right?
Extra sweep arc to specify. Yeah, I was
going to do that before, man. Ideally,
you really don't want to have to do
that, but
cuz it's like,
have you ever tried training enduro? In
enduro, it just goes the curve just goes
straight up and like it's literally it
goes up faster with fewer environments
because it's just you solve it very
quickly and it's just a matter of how
quickly you can run the environment to
get more score.
Oh, this one doesn't even bother with
the Yeah. Okay. This model is just
stupid. I swear. I don't know why it's
like
it's like every bloody time I I try to
check like try to use the model it's
like
maybe this time it won't waste my
like maybe this time it won't waste my time and it's like nope maybe next time.
time and it's like nope maybe next time.
So stupid.
Okay, this was my original
colonel.
Honestly, Habib, I have no idea.
All the models kind of suck. It saves me
time when I use it as fuzzy docks. It
wastes my time every time I try to get
it to do something.
It's literally a meme in this chat that
people just post their favorite LLMs and
then it fails to solve whatever basic
task I'm trying to do. every bloody
time.
Now, I want to check there are a couple
things I want to check. I want to check
first of all if this one has the
gradient with respect to weights.
Correct.
That's a very easy gradient, isn't it?
If it's not a very easy gradient, then I
have something fundamentally
I'm like fundamentally misunderstanding
something about the problem.
Okay, so both gradients are totally
wrong in both implementations.
I don't know what to do about this,
guys, because we need um we need an RMS
form kernel in order to be able to
freaking ship this update.
And this colonel's apparently ass.
Uh
yeah, both of the the weights and the I
mean it's like I don't even have the
freaking analytical gradient for this
thing. Apparently it's more complicated
than I thought.
No, Ford pass is correct. Ford pass is
trivial.
All right, I need a break from this or
I'm going to go [ __ ] insane. So, um
I guess what I'm going to do for right
now is I'm going to see if I can fix
Peru's threading thing so we can at
least get an end to end profile speed.
why do we use these operations through
this [ __ ] Holy hell.
Let's go figure out Peru's threading
thing.
Peru sent me a a threading thing
on X, I believe.
So, let's go find that.
That's like so incredibly obnoxious,
man.
I'm going to set myself aside some time
later this week to just play with this
thing.
has not been declared.
What did I [ __ ] up with the network?
stuff.
Like something stupid like got moved or
something.
Oh, you know what it is? It's this
stupid thing.
Like nothing wrong with this.
And somehow we broke the entire
compilation.
How did this get [ __ ] broken by
shitty RMS norm?
maybe this is conflicting with the torch
name space.
This will give me a better error. But
like
Oh my god. Are you [ __ ] me, dude?
Are you actually [ __ ] me?
If you're developing on Windows and
you're not at least using WSL, you're
just trolling. You don't know what
you're doing
for this type of stuff. Nobody nobody
serious does their dev on Windows. Zero
people.
All right. I hate C++. That's like
disgusting.
This language sucks. Um,
we don't need this.
We just need
Does it really not train?
Well, actually, hang on. I know why it
doesn't train.
It actually trains a little bit, which
is kind of interesting. I didn't realize
it trains like a little bit
like surprisingly decent.
But this is not the uh Yeah, there's
still a gap. But hey, at least we know
the grads are right.
Done is enclosed. No one want that will
always hold the lock.
is enclosed in a while loop
that will always hold the lock.
done is enclosed in a while loop that
will always hold the lock.
Okay. Well, this does not break for now.
Cool.
Is this still broken though? Yeah, it's
still freaking broken. God damn.
Okay. 3.1 mil.
So, we basically need to figure out what
the heck happened to performance then.
And actually, let's just
real quick,
even though this is not super stable,
cuz we're not even right in the right
ballpark right now.
Let's fix this first.
Let me get my coffee as well. Holy hell.
I'm going to do one quick lift to wake
up.
Okay.
So
Let's see if this will tell us
what I have massively screwed up.
It's like a long tail of different [ __ ]
isn't there?
This does not show any
CPU time.
It shows a bunch of CUDA overhead.
I think based on these replies, I will
at least put in some amount of effort to
this
um before I do another round of [ __ ]
with that colonel
at the very least.
Okay. So,
uh, okay. I see it's because of the way
it's sorted. Cool. So, we've got two
profiles here. This will be good data.
So, we've got two
basically identical profiles. I'll put
it as best as I can without covering
everything.
You see that these are pretty much the
same amount of time.
You know, if tiny has gotten good to the
point where like we can just swap it and
it solves my problems, I'm very willing
to do that. Um now
my hope is that there is the flexibility
to write your own kernels
or at least you know maybe maybe the way
we use it is that tiny will output a
kernel for us. I don't know if it'll
output a like well-written kernel or
whatever but if I can get it to output a
kernel that is correct that I can then
manually tune that's also acceptable.
Getting
the gradients right
manually for some of these operations is
just so [ __ ] hard
like the actual programming portion of
this like sure okay I haven't done like
warp synchronization or even like I
haven't done like any like basic block
reduce or anything in CUDA that doesn't
concern me. That [ __ ] is not hard to
figure out. Okay. Like parallelism just
is not that complicated.
Getting the gradients to really fiddly
operations. [ __ ] hell, that's a pain.
Okay, so we have here 1.1 second CPU
uh and 400 ms CUDA.
Now, we're going to figure out
where this stuff comes from.
So I don't understand these overhead
operations. Um
I do see though
the massive massive amount of CPU
overhead time we have here spent on
syncing CUDA streams
and launching kernels.
Now the thing I don't understand right
is
here if we add up these numbers
6 7
8.
It only gets us to like 900 ms CPU time,
right?
These don't match.
Okay, so we're getting to CPU bottleneck
to hell. Anyways, cool.
Uh, let me see if I can figure out
few other things.
I'm going to go check the torch docks
instead of this. Oh, [ __ ]
Skip the first step.
Start warming up on the second.
Fourth.
I did not require all of that [ __ ]
Thank you.
Actually move
shapes.
Um,
It's fine.
Cool.
We'll see if um
if the totals make sense.
Yeah, it's taking forever for to jump
the uh
the averages. is
Okay, that's literally impossible that
it's this.
So, we just take full step time.
Hang on. I think this one should match,
right? So it's
uh
1.76
3.9 mil
too high
Yeah. And you sort by totals because
Yeah. Okay, that's fine. So,
yeah, this is
ridiculous, right?
Okay.
Figure out what the [ __ ] is going on
here.
Okay. So, let's comment this stream
sync.
Uh, figuring out why [ __ ] is so slow.
Yes.
New update. Hello Spencer.
I hope you're having a better time than
I am here.
Online PO against a Bronty does find the
bug enough time steps.
Selfplay converge to the same optimal
strategy. That's cool.
That's very cool. Hey, I mean you
definitely have it working if you have
that working off of selfplay. Now you
can actually that is a simple
environment that you can ablate. I mean,
you know, the dynamics can be more
different in a more complex end, but
that's a really nice one
to uh ablate to see like, you know, how
many historical opponents do you need
and stuff like that? Do you need any,
etc., etc.
I am fighting demons, my guy. I am
fighting many demons.
Honestly, Spencer, you could probably
try. I have no idea what types of
behaviors you can get out of MOA at all.
I hope the animations are good enough
for you to be able to like tell if stuff
smart like smart stuff is going on as
well.
But hey, if you get an ELO curve that's
like smooth
and like keeps learning stuff,
mobile chess, like there a lot of Ms
that you can do it on. I'm just going to
be fighting her for a while, man. It's
tough.
It's really obnoxious.
ELO looks whack because both players end
up cheating and that's just who gets the
ball more. Well, presumably there's a
curve until then,
Yeah, there it is. And it falls off
steeply.
yeah. So
I don't know how um
shouldn't fall off once it finds that
strat, though.
There might be some weird pork with
that.
try on another M. That is great news.
That is great news.
So, uh I have lots of good kernel
optimizations, but there's like a ton of
CPU overhead that I'm currently tracking
down.
I also don't have a good RMS norm kernel
yet, but apparently this is more of a
pressing issue anyways.
every single iteration.
Okay. So that is 64
I think it's uh it's very appropriate
that we get our our first intern is
named Finn.
If Spencer can get it done in time,
which um I think that Spencer, you're
going to have plenty of time because
this stuff is like this is brutal.
I don't think there's any way I get this
done by end of year. I'm going to work
as much as I can, but it's like
the good news is I think if if I do
manage to get this done regardless,
like puffer 5 is a much more
self-contained thing.
So,
I think infer wise it's not that bad
either.
Glad to be part of puffer of puff.
How easy will it be to merge?
Just I have no idea. I'm going to make
this [ __ ] easier, but I It's going to
get harder before it gets easier.
We will see whether this whether I've
screwed up in my kernels. I don't know
where I would have for syncs at least.
Well, let me make sure it's even from
the Ford Pass.
I don't know if this will actually work
or if this will just crash, but
Okay. So, it is in the forward pass
somewhere. You see, it's in the forward
pass.
Um,
try this one.
I mean, it's in it's in the compile eval
at least.
What the [ __ ] does this even mean?
Serious issue.
Correctness is a serious issue.
Interesting. Okay, so it is actually
it's synchronizing a [ __ ] ton for some
reason.
And the easier thing would just be to
synchronize.
Uh this is at the moment this is getting
rid of CPU overhead. So optimizing CPU
overhead plus good kernel should give us
10 mil.
But like Torch just does utterly stupid
[ __ ] all the time for no
Basically, I don't know which of these
ops do this [ __ ]
Well, we should probably just like
There's a lot easier way to test this.
Good.
Okay, that did nothing. Good job.
Literally nothing.
Okay, so they're all in the forward
pass. Rock is stupid. All in the
freaking forward pass somewhere.
I think I found it, But
I think I found it.
implicit copying without telling me is
so evil.
Implicit uh synchronize without telling
me is so evil.
I learn programmer coding if you are
interested in
So, if this does not change Perf,
where else would it even be?
Yeah. So, it's not here
clearly.
Let's take dim.
No. So, can I just return X?
>> Well, you don't learn cyber security
without learning programming.
I mean, this is obviously faster because
we've no opted, but um
which profile just takes forever as well
with these settings.
I'm going to change it actually because
it's just like unbearable.
That doesn't make any sense, does it?
It should be 35.
profile is just so stupid. How's it
taking that long?
Uh times five
times four is exactly the same as
before, right?
Yeah. Times four.
Exactly the same number of calls.
You know, the thing that just sucks
about this type of work is you can work
all day and get nothing. Like, you can
actually make no meaningful progress.
It's ridiculous.
Nothing will burn you up quicker than
working on stuff like all day and not
making any meaningful progress.
Okay. So, it's not the mining grew
somehow.
Yeah. I mean, you learn stuff, but you
learn like [ __ ] that shouldn't
exist.
Still 157. How,
dude? Like how?
should be zero synchronizations for
[ __ ] sake.
I swear I profiled that before, but
whatever, I guess.
till 12:50.
Weird, isn't it?
It's just doing way too many
synchronized operations and I don't
understand Bye.
It's a 290.
And then let's see
does this rise predictably
from 290. Okay.
The 610. Okay,
this is predictable.
I assert that to here it should still be
610.
and these buffers as well.
Oh, hang on.
I bet you this is just like moving
devices and I'm being stupid.
chess be like kicks rocks and trippy
claps one kicks rocks best model yet.
Yeah, man. I This is why we want like
stable regions. This is one of the
things constellation is meant to fix.
Material reward shaping has been good.
Added that back in. Good
fuel.
Need to train more.
We can run some stuff on the boxes for a
bit. If you have stuff ready to go
literally just forgotten on blocking.
Total doofus.
Okay, this is the expected
610.
Now, this should go up by uh what? 320
Uh, it was 610, not 610.
This is good.
So the only sinks now we got rid of
these
If you have stuff to run, I have like
just run boxes behind me. We can run
from stuff.
Um,
we typically we do contracts for client
work.
Like I make zero money directly off of
this. This is all open source.
So the only revenue we get is from
client work directly. And then we do
bring people in on that. It is pretty
much only people who I've worked with
directly and have been doing stuff
around Puffer.
right. I hate this stupid thing, but
whatever.
And then if I get the synchronizations
down to just the ones that we need for
um env, then we'll basically know the
exact overhead of uh of env copying
around.
no way more than 16. 16 times
like 64.
Yeah. 8 down to 850.
So, there just a few more of these in
here somewhere.
I mean, these are a couple, but these
don't really do much.
Uh, there are
no things that should synchronize.
I see no things that should synchronize
here.
The dot items are obvious.
Yeah, this does it. Cool.
well. Yeah, this has to get synced.
I think I screwed this up, man.
Duh.
Wait, no, that shouldn't cause a
I got to go get dinner in a second. I
won't understand this.
Is this thing hanging?
God damn.
Good job. The torture. You very or Gro,
you're very stupid.
Uh
oh. I wonder if I do this
comment my entire
entire loop.
Yesesh.
See if this is still 6 or 850 syncs.
690. Okay, so 696.
Let me see.
Uh 850
690. I don't know why I do that. 170.
Let's see. 170
by 16 / 5
can't be by 16 then, can it?
I think that they're two.
There are probably two synchronizations
in there.
by 690
correct number.
Oh wait, which is the correct number?
Right.
Hang on.
That wouldn't make any sense. I think
it's just making [ __ ] up on me now. What
do you guys think?
I mean, this is very easy for us to just
fuse the clip into the optimizer, right?
If it is, in fact, this would be the
easiest one.
Damn, it is synchronizing.
But actually, there's more than that
that's synchronizing as well.
That's annoying.
Links are here without
this 90 all
50.
What were we expecting again? So it was
um 64 times
40. Ah, so then yeah, that's pretty
close. Okay. Well, I got to go get
dinner, folks. Um, thank you for tuning
in. I think I got some client work that
I got to do after this.
I can't just be working on the open
source stuff all the time.
Uh so I'm going to do that and then I'm
going to try to get I'm going to try to
get some longer hours in this week
honestly because that's what it's going
to take to get this thing shipped.
There's just so much PF optimization to
do. Like
this is at least gone down a lot, right?
What are we at now?
This is still awful.
So all these syncs are killing us. These
kernel launches. This will be handled
through fusion though. And then we got
to figure out what the heck is up with
like the matmo CPU overhead. That's
weird. there like a few things we got to
deal with here. But yeah, I think
I mean the good news is even with this.
This is 3 mil.
I'm pretty sure
like literally this means just if we cut
some CPU overhead, we're at 10 mil.
Let alone like the fact that we're the
optimizations are literally this
overhead is ridiculous. Anyways though,
thank you folks. Uh, if you want to help
me out for absolutely free, puffer.ai.
Star the puffer. Feed him a star. He
likes stars. Join Discord if you want to
get involved. Fall on X for more
content, including my educ